okay first of all Lewis have you had
chicken parmesan I have no I've not
today about how about the bread up 32 oh
you had a burrito so would winning
record of the song of the year actually
be like having a burrito since you had
it to me I mean I may be losing it be
like having a burrito
oh so Winnie would be like chicken parm
losing would be like ham because I feel
like when you lose when you have a
pretty oh it doesn't set as nice it's
not as nice and feeling as a chicken pop
so yeah I think losing is a burrito and
I'm preparing to lose today so I'll go
over Rio just so I was ready wait a
minute okay so you're going into is this
just going into it with low expectation
so you don't like no I mean when you're
in the same car get is like belly less
or tell us well I mean it's like you
don't expect to what if your song wasn't
one of the best it wouldn't be nominated
so come on we got to go into this
thinking positively move associative
thinking we're gonna do it come on
first-time nominee and you're up for a
song of the year let's stay like that
that's the winners pose that's what you
go for the rest of the interview for
sure ask away
alright first-time nominee and you have
song of the year yeah what the heck goes
through your mind when that happen
that's like a freight train bound for
bonefoot as they quote meatloaf that's
like a bio hell my brains like a it's
going crazy I'm a I'm like a bat out of
hell
you win maybe it'll be paradise by the
dashboard lights what about that we are
and sync and I love it I love it we see
each other yeah I'm like yeah I'm a [ __ ]
I'm hoping it's a chicken parm kind of
night for you Lois I'm holding just like
chicken pop
[Music]